hey james murphy here with m coding in
this episode we're talking about
positional only and keyword only
arguments in python
this is a normal function definition
with three arguments a b and c
as is we can pass any of the arguments
as either positional or keyword
arguments
here we pass them all as positional
arguments
and here we give all keyword arguments
the order of the arguments doesn't
matter when we use keyword arguments
and we can mix and match passing some
parameters as positional and some as
keyword arguments
you do have to pass all of your
positional arguments first though so
this is an error
this gives callers of the function f a
lot of flexibility in how they want to
call it
but sometimes we don't want to give them
all that flexibility
and for those cases we can actually
require that certain arguments are
passed as positional arguments or
require that they're passed as keyword
arguments let's see how syntactically
you would make an argument either
positional or keyword only and then more
importantly let's see why you would ever
want to do this
let's start with keyword only arguments
inside your parameters put a star
the arguments before the star can still
be passed either as positional or
keyword arguments
things after the star now have to be
passed as keyword arguments
or they could be omitted if they have a
default value i guess obviously if you
try to pass a keyword argument as a
positional argument you get a syntax
error
we're going to have stars and slashes
and star stars and it might be a bit
tricky to remember
here's the way that you should remember
that everything after the star is a
keyword argument
recall what star args does
star args eats all remaining positional
arguments
in this case our positional arguments
are 1 and 2 which line up with a and b
there aren't any more positional
arguments so args just becomes the empty
tuple
if we pass additional positional
arguments
that's where they show up
okay great args swallows up anything
that's positional
so logically anything that comes after
star args can't be positional
otherwise it would have just been part
of args
so this is actually another way to force
an argument to be a keyword only
argument
anything that comes after star args or
star whatever variable name must be a
keyword only argument
that's how i remember that everything
after a star is keyword only
i'm just imagining it's short for star
args but i don't care about the args
variable
but the plain star actually has a
benefit over using star args
unlike star args the plane star does not
swallow up all the rest of the
positional arguments
so this call where i have four
positional arguments is an error
whereas if i used star args that 3 and 4
would just get swallowed up
this can be a problem because it gives
the accidental opportunity to pass in
something that you didn't mean to
you could check to see if there were any
extraneous positional arguments that
were passed in and then raise an error
if there are
but that's just a lot of extra
unnecessary work
instead just use a star and don't give
it a name
okay but why would you want a keyword
only argument
keyword-only arguments are most often
used as options or settings that
slightly vary or modify the behavior of
some code
this combined function just takes two
iterables and then puts them one after
another into a big list
maybe we want to add some kind of
validation to this function if you
passed in a callable validator then we
check that all the elements are valid
we could just leave validator as a
normal argument
but then it's possible someone sees a
correct usage of this combine sub and
scribe
and maybe they don't quite look at the
documentation and they think that they
can just combine any number of things
in this case we will get an error but
it's not the one that i would hope we
get
the string is taken as the validator
then we'll get a crash when we try to
use the string as a callable object
which it's not
if the thing that i tried to pass here
happened to have a similar enough
interface to a validator we might have
gotten the worst case
no errors at all a silent wrong answer
instead we use a star and make validator
a keyword only argument
now this caller will get the correct
error that they passed too many
positional arguments
you can also use this to force your
caller to spell out exactly what
argument they're passing in
this can be useful if you really really
want to make sure that two arguments
aren't mixed up
you wouldn't want to mix up buying 10
000 of something at a price of 4 500 and
buying 4 500 of something at a price of
10 000.
using keyword arguments can minimize the
risk of this very plausible human error
what about positional only arguments
here's the syntax in your argument list
put a slash there's no equivalent of
starags for slash this is the only way
you use it any parameters before the
slash must be passed as positional
so it ends up looking like this
positional arguments first
then the slash then normal arguments
they can be passed either as positional
or keyword arguments then a star then
keyword-only arguments
you can even throw in star star quarks
to catch all remaining keyword arguments
i know this notation is kind of annoying
to remember i always start with the star
star is like star args that eats all
positional arguments
anything to the right is keyword
arguments and the things to the very
left must be positional
of course you can mix and match all of
these
a slash directly followed by a star is a
common pattern to force all of the
arguments to either be positional only
or keyword only a slash at the end means
everything is positional
a star at the beginning means everything
is keyword only
but the only way to really get the hang
of it is to just try a few
okay now what are the actual use cases
for positional only arguments
consider this function check truthy it
checks that the argument x is truthy and
otherwise raises an error the context of
this function is incredibly general
it wouldn't be specific to any
particular domain or part of a program
so why is its argument name x
well it's named x because variables need
names and i just picked x
but x is not a meaningful name for this
argument and i claim that there really
is no meaningful name
i mean you could call it object or
something like that but is that really
that meaningful
when you use this function just pass in
whatever you want to check as truthy
this argument is best portrayed just as
the argument to the function
it doesn't need and it shouldn't have a
name like x
so in this case we use the slash at the
end of the argument list to force it to
be a positional only argument
if i do this then at some later time i'd
be free to change the name x to
something else
for instance later i might want to
decide that i want to check any number
of arguments for truthiness
i can change x into star valves and then
loop over the x's
because none of the people calling this
function referred to the variable x this
is now a completely backwards compatible
change
another use case that i find often comes
up with positional arguments is when the
placement of the variables mimics some
kind of mathematical expression
in this case i'm looking at raising x to
the y power and taking it mod some
number
in this case the names x and y don't
really convey which one is being raised
to the other power
it's more the fact that x comes first
and y comes second that x is being
raised to the y
and in this case i think actually
specifying the modulus this way makes it
even more clear
so to me it makes sense to additionally
make mod a keyword only argument
what about all three is there any case
where you really want positional only
positional or keyword and keyword only
in fact there are zero examples of this
in the entire python standard library
with the exception of the tests that
this feature works there are a few cases
though where you do this
where all of the arguments are
positional only or keyword only
the best example i could find of this is
actually the data class decorator
data classes have tons of different
features that you can turn on and off
so those make sense as keyword only
arguments
but dataclass is a decorator so by
definition it takes a single callable as
an argument
so i guess yeah that makes sense
whatever it applies to is the unique
positional argument
and finally let's do a speed test
are positional arguments faster than
keyword arguments
and what if they're positional only or
keyword only arguments how do the
timings of all of those compare
don't bother reading all the code
exactly here's the setup
i have a normal function with three
regular parameters
and i call it with positional keyword
arguments out of order keyword arguments
and a mixture then i redefine the
function making everything positional
only
again time that then redefine again and
make everything keyword only
and then time that in order and out of
order then i just print out all the
times and here the timing results all
the numbers are in nanoseconds so these
are all really fast it's pretty clear
there's a slight but statistically
significant difference
we have 77 and 78
and any of the variations that used any
keyword arguments used at least 95
nanoseconds so yes positional arguments
are faster than keyword arguments
it didn't seem to make any difference if
they were positional only versus if you
just happened to pass them as positional
thank you all for listening that's all
i've got thank you to my patrons and
donors for supporting me if you enjoy my
content please consider becoming a
patron on patreon
as always don't forget to subscribe and
slap that like button an odd number of
times
see you next time